multiplica y expresa el resultado como
una expresión racional simplificada
indica cuál es el dominio ok y entonces
tenemos aquí nuestra multiplicación y
empecemos por indicar cuál es el dominio
los únicos números que podrían hacer que
esta expresión no estuviera bien
definida son aquellos números que
podrían hacer que el denominador fuera
igual a 0 y eso pasa solo si a b x oye
alguno de ellos es igual a 0 aunque
entonces ya sabemos cuál es el dominio
vamos a escribirlo por qué
dos niños son todos los reales
todos los números reales
de alex a de equis y excepto el cero
todo
el 0 el ave x y se pueden tomar
cualquier valor en los números reales
excepto el 0 bueno creo que esta no es
una buena forma de escribirlo entonces
vamos a abordarlo y vamos a poner dado
que
de x todas estas variables son distintas
de 0 aunque entonces ya tenemos el
dominio y podemos proseguir haciendo la
multiplicación así es que tenemos que
multiplicar este por este y eso se hace
multiplicando numerador con numerador y
después dividiendo entre denominador por
denominador entonces empezamos con los
numeradores tenemos aquí
x cuadrada y por 14 cuadrada me y a eso
lo dividimos entre 2 a b2
por 18 x de cuadrada 10 y 8 x de
cuadrada y listo ya tenemos la
multiplicación ya nada más nos falta
simplificar esta expresión así es que
pues aquí podemos dividir el 2 entre 2 y
el 14 entre 2 entonces pues vamos a
hacerlo 14 entre 2 nos queda simplemente
un 7 y 2 entre 2 nos queda un 1 también
podemos dividir el 18 entre 3 y el 3
entre 3 y entonces nos queda 3 entre 31
y 18 entre 36 y por acá tenemos aquí una
ahí tenemos aquí a cuadrada entonces
vamos a dividir a entre a y nos queda un
y cuadrada entre a y nos queda
simplemente a y de la misma forma vamos
a dividir x cuadrada entre x si nos
queda simplemente x y aquí dividimos x
entre x si nos queda un 1 y dividimos b
entre vecinos cada uno b / b nos queda
un 1 y finalmente ya entre y nos queda
un 1 y ye cuadrada entre que nos queda
ya y en cada una de estas cosas que
hicimos dividimos el numerador y el
denominador por exactamente la misma
cosa entonces en realidad no estamos
cambiando la expresión entonces todo
esto es igual a 1 x x x 1 x x 7 x a x 1
por 7 por a entre uno por uno por uno
por uno por seis por seis
aunque entonces esta ya es una expresión
nacional simplificada pero le tenemos
que agregar la restricción de que ni a
ni b ni equis ni ya pueden ser iguales a
0 que es muy importante poner esta
restricción ya sé que puede parecer como
que no tiene sentido pero si lo tienen
ok aunque aquí ni la an y la equis si
las ponemos iguales a cero hacen que
esta expresión esté indeterminada sea
indefinida de todas formas tenemos que
poner esta restricción y no se diga de
la b o sea la de ni siquiera aparece en
esta expresión racional pero bueno es
muy importante poner esta restricción
porque si no esta expresión y esta otra
expresión no son iguales como funciones
aunque hay digamos que ésta es una
función
x que en realidad es una función de a b
x y para que esta expresión como función
sea igual a esta otra función sus
dominios tienen que ser iguales así es
que es muy importante poner esta
restricción si realmente quieres que
éstos sean iguales
tienes que ponerles las mismas
restricciones